leur vente repoussent leurs questions
aussi ces femmes participent à mon
parcours maternité un dispositif de la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines
il s'adresse surtout aux femmes
enceintes de trois à six mois de
grossesse
c'est un atelier qui est destiné à leur
expliquer les démarches administratives
qui sont nombreuses lorsqu'on attend un
premier enfant qui sont souvent aussi
méconnue de qu'on leur explique en
détail ce que ça recouvre d'être
enceinte et d'être aussi assurer des
yvelines et on explique les modes de
relation attendu à la fois par la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie mais
également par les autres organismes
institutionnels
quels sont les droits au congé maternité
et paternité les examens obligatoires
tout au long de la grossesse
ce premier atelier est un temps
d'échangé auquel sont conviés les jeunes
mamans mais pas seulement
le congé paternité que alors on en avait
j'en avais déjà entendu parler mais sans
savoir exactement comment il était
comment ils étaient formulées sur les
indemnités également au niveau du congé
maternité puisque congé maternité c'est
des mots qu'on entend tous les jours
mais on sait pas derrière ce que ça ce
que cela représente
intéressée pourra voir les nouveautés en
fait pour les femmes enceintes et après
la naissance pour le bébé et tout
qu'est-ce que je bénéfices de l'année
c'est l'assurance maladie les frais tout
c'est bien c'est bien organisé
c'est convivial personnes sont assez à
l'écouté on peut poser nos questions des
questions qu'on peut pas forcément posé
sur le site donc c'est vraiment je pense
que c'est vraiment une bonne idée pour
pour tout le monde
autant pour les mamans que pour les
futurs papas le prochain atelier portera
lui sur la prévention santé
un coach sportif informera sur le
sommeil ou encore le mal de dos